be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is begin our
lead-up to Civil War - by having a
really quick discussion about all-new
all-different Thanos and what I'm hoping
is that at the end of this you'll have a
better understanding of how he exists in
the new Marvel Universe as well as how
he ties directly into the events that
will start with Civil War - so like most
of Marvel's publications in all-new
all-different marvel Thanos serves as a
holdover from before the collapse of the
multiverse with his return making direct
reference to the actions of Reed
Richards and the events of secret Wars
to sidetrack for a second with The
Ultimates launching as the second wave
of rollouts for all-new all-different
model the cohesiveness of Marvel's
cosmic opera began to take shape as a
self-contained series of events
involving but not necessarily tying in
to earthbound events as an example with
black panther existing on the team as
one of its most intelligent members next
to blue marvel his role was explained in
that his sister Cherie still remained
deceased following the events leading
into secret wars with the charla
returning to a position as king and
attempting to resurrect sharees body but
proving unsuccessful conversely with
Ultimates debuting prior to the official
launch of Captain Marvel issue number
one chronologically Carol Danvers was
established as having already taken over
her role as head of sword the sentient
world observation and response
department which exists to analyze
cosmic threats to earth and cataloged
them for future reference using her
resources and intelligence data to
assist the Ultimates in their mission
the first story arc saw the group
turning their attention to Galactus
leading into the events of civil war -
referencing my video on his character
where the team operated to cure Galactus
on his hunger allowing al Ewing to focus
on how the all-new all-different
universe relates to the precinct rewards
universe where they Ultimates had
traveled beyond all known space and
their attempts to understand and protect
the universe Galactus to capture the
group and taken them back to the normal
universe and advertently creating a tear
in space and time
emerging from the terror in debuting in
the all-new all-different model
landscape al Ewing established that
where the conclusion of the main secret
Wars event had led us as the reader to
believe that Thanos had been killed
after challenging dooms authority and
power through taunts on battle world
because Reed Richards had to use the
power of the beyonders to reset time to
the moment after the most
versus collapsed but before doom could
usurp the beyonders power Reid had
killed the be honors himself and reality
was restored and recreated with Thanos
surviving as a prisoner in the space
outside the multiverse leading into the
events of Civil War to proper where the
principles of cosmic cubes had been
studied and reformed by project Pegasus
the potential energy group alternate
sources united states which focus on
alternate forms of energy for power and
weaponry with various extraterrestrial
races monitoring the planet earth and
their attempt to ensure humanity did not
become a threat to the universe after
scouring the spaceways and discovering a
Shiar Space Station which had been
cataloguing project Pegasus involvement
of the Cosmic Cube Thanos had overheard
the Shiar scientists conversation and
looked to attain the cube for himself
killing everyone on board following his
interrogation and travelling to earth
the lead-up to civil war 2 came into
play with the introduction of the
inhuman Ulysses taking place in Marvel's
2016 free comic book day release as well
as the first half of civil war issue
number one with Ulysses having developed
the power to see the future after being
exposed to the Terrigen mists the
Inhumans were warned of Thanos impending
attack with the all-new all-different
Avengers Ultimates and Inhumans
responding killing war machine during
the fight and injuring she-hulk to the
point of hospitalization and eventual
death while the rest of the story saw
the eventual kickoff of the Civil War 2
event
Thanos himself was locked away in stasis
with no indication of what the Avengers
intended to do with him with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end and next Wednesday we'll continue
the process of going through the lead-up
to civil war eventually stepping into
the actual events of Civil War 2 and I
will catch you guys later peace